jeff bezos ce tim cook sundar pichai et
mark zuckerberg sont convoqués au
capitole aujourd'hui ils devront tour à
tour répondre aux questions de l'agencé
en charge de la protection des
consommateurs
la federal trade commission son but
savoir si les fameux gaffard abusent de
leur position dominante pour écraser la
concurrence google et facebook sont
pointés du doigt pour s'être accaparé
l'essentiel des recettes mondial de la
publicité en ligne
de leur côté amazon com apple sont
accusés d'être juge et partie sur leurs
plateformes respectives
jeff bezos ce qui a publié son discours
sur le blog du groupe prévoit de
défendre son empire il rappelle son rôle
en matière de création d'emplois et fait
jouer la carte sensible de la success
story à l'américaine
le patron revient sur sa naissance d'une
mère lycéenne et d'un père immigrant et
sur celle d'amazon dans un garage de son
côté mark zuckerberg milliardaire à la
tête de facebook prévoit lui aussi de
jouer la carte patriotique présentant
facebook comme une entreprise fièrement
américaine qui n'auraient pas réussi
sans les lois encourageant la
compétition et l'innovation
nous croyons dont certaines valeurs la
démocratie la compétition l'inclusion la
liberté d'expression sur lesquels
l'économie américaine a été bâti il n'y
a pas de garantie que nos valeurs vont
gagner
la chine par exemple construit sa propre
version d'internet sur des idées très
différentes et exporte cette vision dans
d'autres pays
les parlementaires vont donc tenter de
déterminer si les quatre géants du web
domine grâce à des pratiques illégales
visant à écarter la concurrence si tel
était le cas les états unis pourraient
prendre des mesures contre ces
entreprises pour l'heure si le rendez
vous est pris entre les quatre patrons
et le congrès américain rien n'atteste
de leur présence physique au capitole ce
qui compliquerait drastiquement les
débats